seine evelyn chuck ist wohl das was man
eine moderne frau nimmt sie ist gebildet
fährt auto kleidet sich ließ ihr gefällt
und all das in einem staat in dem männer
das sagen haben in magie senat ist auf
dem weg zu einer konferenz sie ist
aktivistin einer jugendbewegung und
kämpft gegen die diktatur in dem
westafrikanischen land ich bin malerin
mit einem pass und einer
staatsbürgerschaft dieses land bedeutet
mir alles ich will nicht dass es in
einen abgrund stürzt
vergangenes jahr putschte das militär
den ehemaligen offizier als ziemlich
leute an die macht freie wahlen hat er
auf jahre verschoben mali wird mehr und
mehr zu einer diktatur die 27 jährige
sänger für das nicht akzeptieren und
schon gar nicht wie sie von militärs
regiert werden
wir können kein land sein das von waffen
regiert wird wenn ein militär an die
macht kommt verbietet dass seine
militärische rolle dass er ein
politisches amt bekleidet
man kann nicht in einem land leben das
sich in einem ewigen übergang befindet
wir sind verpflichtet somalischen
verfassung zurückzukehren und die
demokratie einzuführen also die macht
durch wahlen zu verleihen
maly war lange ein stabiler staat sei
dschihadisten das land mit terror
überziehen ist es das nicht mehr gewalt
ist allgegenwärtig
vor knapp zehn jahren rief die damalige
malische regierung den westen um hilfe
seitdem gibt es immer mehr einsätze und
missionen auch mit beteiligung
deutschlands die sicherheitslage aber
ist weiter prekär nahezu täglich werden
menschen ermordet hunderttausende sind
auf der flucht das land ist zerrissen
wenn seine anhänger genosse denn das
gehirn adamah band jahre ist der
anführer einer anti französischen
bewegung die die militärregierung
marlies unterstützt seine parole immer
die gleiche frankreich die verhasste
ehemalige kolonialmacht soll sofort
abbauen mali soll wieder selbstbestimmt
sein mit russland als partner an der
seite
wir denken dass frankreich den
westlichen angriffen mariann führt genau
wie in allen anderen frankophonen
ländern das muss aufhören frankreich
muss gehen so einfach ist es
dass die russischen partner truppen
möglicherweise an kriegsverbrechen gegen
malia beteiligt gewesen sind ist hier
fielen egal
die russen sind partner sie sind
gekommen um uns zu helfen
und um unsere würde wieder herzustellen
[Musik]
die töne auf dem platz der
unabhängigkeit werden immer aggressiver
dass staatspräsident das semi kräuter
sichern die macht geputscht hat egal und
auch egal ist es den menschen hier dass
das land zunehmend isoliert ist die
propaganda der militärregierung wird
wir erleben jetzt den spektakulären
aufstieg unserer verteidigungs und
sicherheitskräfte etwas dass frankreich
in neun jahren nicht geschafft hat
derzeit gibt es keine berichte über neue
orte die angegriffen werden keine
militärlager werden alle gegriffen oder
von terroristen kontrolliert
er hat andere erfahrungen gemacht und er
hat angst wir nennen in mohammed seinen
richtigen namen dürfen wir nicht sagen
denn der 28 jährige hat als übersetzer
für die bundeswehr gearbeitet
maly so sagt er würde im völligen chaos
versinken wenn die westlichen truppen
abzügen
wir möchten dass alle ausländer dass die
deutschen in unserer nähe bleiben und
unterstützen uns helfen versuchen zu
verhandeln und sicherstellen dass unser
land stabil ist weil wir uns frieden es
ist jahre her dass wir in ruhe schlafen
kann
noch hofft mohammed und wünscht sich nur
eines ein leben in frieden die deutschen
die derzeit in der un mission - mal mit
rund 900 soldatinnen im norden malis
dienst tun würden wirklich gebraucht
dort im norden malis ist die
sicherheitslage besonders angespannt es
ist der größte und gefährlichste einsatz
der bundeswehr im ausland immer wieder
kommt es auch in ihrem camp in gau zu
anschlägen bisher allerdings ohne tote
die deutschen soldatinnen und soldaten
sind in der un-mission wesentlich dafür
verantwortlich
militärische aufklärung zu betreiben und
die region nach verdächtigen
auffälligkeiten zu überwachen wenn die
franzosen bald abziehen wird das
schwieriger
bedeute in erster linie dass die
terroristen hier sind zum einen al qaida
und auf der anderen seite islamische
staat mehr bewegungsfreiheit hat mehr
handlungsoptionen hat die werden aktiver
werden und ich gehe davon aus dass die
sicherheitslage sich verschlechtern wird
auch serien ab sagt sie können nicht
mehr ruhig schlafen sie fürchtet den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt marlies
die zukunft ihrer generation stehe auf
dem spiel immer schwieriger wird es für
sie sich gegen die unterstützer der
militärregierung hier in einem radio
talk gehört zu verschaffen und immer
gefährlicher
auch wenn sie in der minderheit ist der
27 jährigen ist es egal sie will weiter
kämpfen gegen die diktatur und
selbsternannte machthaber regelmäßig
demonstrieren sie und ihre anhänger für
schnelle und freie wahlen
in einer diktatur kann man nicht
sprechen sich nicht äußern und seine
rechte nicht einfordern und das lehnen
wir ab wir brauchen also ein
demokratisches regime
eine breite mehrheit in mali aber will
lieber die militärregierung akzeptieren
als sich weiter vom westen sinken zu
lassen so ist molly innenpolitisch
gespalten und außenpolitisch isoliert
welchen weg ich einschlagen wird ist
ungewiss
[Musik]